JOINED FROM KYIV YUCK, BY PETER
ZALMAYEV HE'S THE DIRECTOR OF
THE RACIAL DEMOCRACY
INITIATIVE.
PETER, THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH
US, WE HAD AN ADVISER TO
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY, APPARENTLY
TRYING THE RUSSIANS, AFTER A
FEW DAYS OF ATTACK, SAID THAT
IF KREMLIN DID NOT SO YOU
ASTRONOMY, THEY KNOW THAT IF
SOMETHING WAS LAUNCHED INTO
ANOTHER COUNTRIES ARE SPACE,
SOONER ALLY LATER OUR --
SEEMS PRETTY OBVIOUS WHAT
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT.
SO SEEMING UKRAINE IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE ATTACKS,
HOW DOES THIS RAISE THE STAKES?
ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING THE
FRONT TO USE ALL AVAILABLE
MEANS TO DEFEND RUSSIA, THAT
WAS INTERPRETED TO INCLUDE IN
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
>> INDEED, FIRST OF, ALL THE
UKRAINIANS HAVE PERFECTED THIS
ART OF TROLLING THE RUSSIANS.
AND THIS IS ANOTHER EVIDENCE OF
THAT.
THEY'RE BEING COY ABOUT WHAT
NEW TECHNOLOGY UKRAINE HAS BEEN
ABLE TO TECH DEVELOP.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, THERE IS
DEVELOPMENT HAPPENING ON THE
TERRITORY OF UKRAINE, AS FAR AS
BEEN PRODUCED.
3 TO 400, HUNDRED 50 MILES DEEP
BEHIND THE FRONT LINES.
WHETHER IF THAT THESE TINY
DIRECTLY ESCALATION, I THINK
THIS IS JUST KIND OF ABSURD TO
ASSUME THAT RUSSIA WITH JUST
WAGE THIS WAR ON A TERRITORY,
OF UKRAINE, AND NOT EXPECT
ANYTHING TO HIT IT BACK.
YOU, NOW YOU REPORT YOU SO,
ESSENTIALLY.
I WOULDN'T WORRY TOO MUCH ABOUT
THIS ESCALATION, BECAUSE YOU
HAVE TO KEEP IN, MIND FLOODING
PUTIN HAS ALREADY BEEN A PAINS
TO CONVINCE RUSSIANS, THAT
THEY'RE AT WAR NOT WITH UKRAINE,
BUT THEY ARE AT WAR WITH NATO.
SO IN THE MINDS OF THE RUSSIANS,
RUSSIA IS WAGING A WAR WITH
NATO --
GLENN REPUGNANCE SAID, --
YOU KNOW, UKRAINE HAS BEEN
STRIKING ONE AFTER ANOTHER
AFTER ANOTHER, NOT TAKING FULL
RESPONSIBILITY BEHIND IN FINE
LINES.
BUSINESSES DAVIS'S EVER GOTTEN,
PUTIN DOES NOT HAVE A CLEAR
ANSWER TO THAT.
I THINK THAT DETERRENCE IS
WORKING, WHO'S GONNA SEND A
SIGNAL BY THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY, INCLUDING THE
CHINESE.
AND BACK >> AND BACK IN OCTOBER,
THERE'S A STATEMENT BY
UKRAINIAN STATE OWNED WEAPON
MANUFACTURERS.
>> A NEW LONG-RANGE JOB WITH A
RANGE OF 3000 KILOMETERS.
>> THIS IS SIGNIFICANT
MILITARILY.
.
>> I THINK FIRST OF ALL OF THE
QUESTION OF FAIRNESS.
YOU BRING MORE TO ANOTHER
COUNTRY, HAVE YOU EXPECT WARD
ARRIVE YOUR OWN DOOR STAFF.
IT'S ALREADY PRODUCED WAVES OF
CONCERN, THE MAYORS OF THESE
TOWNS WHERE THIS HAPPENED OF
SCRAMBLE TO ENSURE THAT
POPULATIONS AT ALL AS WELL.
I'M NOT SURE TO BE AN IMMEDIATE
THREAT TO VLADIMIR PUTIN'S
REGIME.
UKRAINE DEVELOPS ENOUGH OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY, AND IS ABLE TO
STRIKE, THESE ARE MILITARY
TARGETS FOR TALKING ABOUT SOME
OF THEM APPARENTLY WERE
LAUNCHING, STAGING GROUNDS FOR
THESE PLANES TO TAKE OFF AND
BOMBER TERRITORY, AND IT COULD
ACTUALLY MILITARILY,
SIGNIFICANTLY DEGRADE RUSSIA'S
ABILITY TO WAGE WAR AGAINST
UKRAINE.
AS FAR AS UKRAINE, THE
POPULATION OF RUSSIA'S PROBABLY
LESS ACTIVE, UNLESS COURAGEOUS
IN THE POPULATION OF CHINA,
THAT'S RISEN UP AGAINST COVID
RESTRICTIONS.
>> THIS IS A CLEAR
DEMONSTRATION OF WHAT HAPPENED
TO THE COUNTRY, WHEN YOU HAVE A
LEADER IN POWER FOR 22 YEARS,
THAT IS DIVERTED ALL
INSTITUTIONS, AND INSTILLED,
GREAT GREAT FEAR AMONGST THOSE
PEOPLE.
>> AND THE IMMEDIATE RESPONSE
FROM MOSCOW IS TO LAUNCH THE
EIGHTH ATTACK, SPECIFICALLY
TARGETING THE POWER OF THE
STRUCTURE IN UKRAINE.
WHAT'S KIND OF SURPRISING IS
STILL FUNCTIONING.
IT HAS REDUCED CAPACITY, IF
ANYTHING THIS LAST ATTACK DID
NOT INCLUDE ANY IRANIAN DRONES,
SEEMS TO BE LESS EFFECTIVE THAN
BEFORE, THAT'S HAPPENING?
HERE >> IT SEEMS THEY MAY HAVE
BEEN, OUT RUSSIANS MAY HAVE RUN
OUT OF UKRAINE TROUNCE, --
AS WE UNDERSTAND, A NEW PORTION
OF THOSE DRONES FROM HER, AND
IT'S NOT CERTAIN THAT YOU GET
THOSE.
AND THEIR EFFICACY HAS ALL ALSO
BEEN SIGNIFICANTLY DEGRADED, --
THE PRETTY EASY TO SHOOT DOWN,
NOT ALL OF THEM ARE, THOUGH AND
EVEN THESE BALLISTIC, MISSILES
LIKE YOU MENTIONED EARLIER, 60
TO 70 WERE SHOT DOWN, THIS
MEANS THAT THE WESTERN SUPPLIED
ANTI AIRCRAFT SYSTEMS, HAVE
BEEN VERY, EFFECTIVE REPORTED
100 PERCENT SUCCESS RATE,
EXPECTING MORE, OBVIOUSLY.
--
IT'S HUGELY SOPHISTICATED, TAKE
A LONG TIME TO LEARN, OBVIOUSLY
WILL NOT HELP IN THE SHORT RUN,
BUT IN THE LONG RUN WE ARE
GONNA BE LIVING MIXES NEIGHBOR
WITH PUTIN OR WITHOUT, IT SEEMS
LIKE IT'S GONNA BE AN
EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO UKRAINE
FOR A LONG TIME TO COME.
>> HI PETER, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BEING, HERE WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME SIR.
>>> THIS MORNING IN UKRAINE, A
WESTERN OFFICIAL TELLS CNN
RUSS HAS RUN OUT IN THE
OFFICIAL'S WORDS OF IRANIAN
ATTACK DRONES.
BUT IS ANTICIPATING A RESUPPLY.
RUSSIA HAS BEEN USING A VARIETY
OF IRANIAN MANUFACTURED DOANS
WHICH HAVE BEEN PART OF THE
ATTACKS ON UKRAINE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
>> AND CIVILIAN TARGETS.
AS RUSSIAN STRIKES REPORTED
OVERNIGHT IN THE SOUTHERN
ZAPORIZHZHIA AND DNIPRO REGION
DAMAGING CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
AND RESIDENTIAL BUILDINGS.
JOINING US NOW TO DISCUSS, MARK
HERTLING FROM THE 7th ARMY.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON LIEUTENANT
GENERAL, TO WALK US THROUGH THE
LATEST DEVELOPMENTS HERE.
A LOT OF QUESTIONS FOR YOU.
FIRST I WONDER, IF YOU COULD
GIVE US A SENSE OF WHERE YOU
THINK THIS WAR IS RIGHT NOW?
UKRAINIANS MADE PROGRESS IN THE
SOUTH, RECAPTURE KHERSON AFTER
MAKING UNEXPECTED PROGRESS IN
THE NORTH A NUMBER OF WEEKS
AGOARN KHARKIV.
RUSSIAS THAT STRUCK BACK BY
HITTING MORE AND MORE CIVILAB
TARGETS.
ARE RUSSIANS RETREATING IN THIS
WAR?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE THAT IS THE
CASE, JIM.
I THINK WHAT IS HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW IS THE DONBAS REGION WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A ARTILLERY
SLUGFEST.
THERE HAS BEEN AN EXCHANGE OF
TOWNS, UKRAINE HAS GAINED A
COUPLE OF MORE TERRITORIES
WITHIN THAT DONBAS REASON IN
SOME TOUGH FIGHTING AND
ARTILLERY DUELS BUT IT IS TOUGH
TO CONDUCT A BREAK THROUGH.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY TO
BREAK THROUGH THE TRENCH LINES
BUT QUICKLY GAINING IT.
IF YOU GO TO THE SOUTHEAST, WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT OVER LAST
COUPLE OF MONTHS IS WE'VE SEEN
SOME GREAT ADVANCES BY UKRAINE
ON THE WESTERN SIDE OF THE
DNIPRO RIVER.
BUT NOW THEY HAVE THE RIVER AS A
NATURAL BARRIER.
EVERY MILITARY COMMANDER HAS TO
CONSIDER ROADS AND RIVER AND
BRIDGES AND TERRAIN FEATURES AND
NOW UKRAINE HAS TO CONDUCT
ATTACKS ACROSS THAT RIVER WHICH
IS IN SOME CASES MILE OR TWO
MILES WIDE TO GET ON THE EASTERN
SIDE TO CONTINUE TO DISRUPT
RUSSIAN FORCES.
THEY'RE DOING THAT BY CONDUCTING
ARTILLERY RAIDS, PRECISION
WEAPONRY TARGETING ON THE
EASTERN SIDE, AGAINST THE
RUSSIANS.
BUT THINK WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
SEE BECAUSE OF LESS DAYLIGHT,
MORE COLD WEATHER, THE FIGHTING
WON'T STOP BUT IT WILL SLOW DOWN
SIGNIFICANTLY.
BUT TRUTHFULLY, JIM, ON BOTH
SIDES, IT IS STILL A TOUGH FIGHT
AND UKRAINE CONTINUES TO GAIN
GROUND.
>> IN TERMS OF WHERE THE WAR
COULD BE SHIFTING, UKRAINE IS
NOT COMMENTING ON THE ALLEGED
DRONE STRIKES WHICH I BELIEVE
WERE UP TO THREE NOW INSIDE OF
RUSSIA AIR BASES AND RUSSIA
TERRITORY.
WHAT DOES THAT SIGNIFY TO YOU?
COULD THIS BE ALSO A NEW PHASE
OF THIS WAR?
>> IT COULD VERY WELL, BE.
ERICA, THAT IS A GREAT QUESTION.
FROM THE UKRAINE SIDE, FIRST OF
ALL, IT WAS A GREAT STRIKE BUT
EVERYONE IS FOCUSING ON THE
HITTING OF THE TARGETS THAT
THOSE THREE AIRFIELDS.
BUT THERE IS A WHOLE LOR MORE TO
FROM A UKRAINIAN GEM STANDPOINT.
THEY HAVE TO GET THE REQUIRED
INTELLIGENCE AND THEN A COMPLEX
SET OF TARGETING DRILLS AND THEN
THEY HAVE TO SINK RONNIZE THE
TRAVEL OF THE WEAPON SYSTEMS AND
THE ELECTRONIC GEAR AFTER THEY
ARECEIVE THEP RUSSIAN AIR
DEFENSE CAPABILITIES OF DEEFTING
THE TARGETS AND I WOULD ALSO
SUGGEST THAT THEY HAVE INCLUDED
SPECIAL OPERATIONS TO DETERMINE
WHERE THE BEST TARGETS WERE AS A
SURPRISE TO THE RUSSIANS.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE RUSSIAN SIDE
FROM A RUSSIAN GENERAL
PERSPECTIVE, FIRST OF ALL,
THEY'RE NUMBER ONE TRAIT IS
HUBRIS.
THEY THINK THAT IS DEFENSIVE
CAPABILITY INSIDE OF RUSSIA FAR
AWAY FROM THE FRONT LINES.
THEY'VE JUST FOUND OUT ON A
COUPLE OF OCCASIONS THEY DON'T.
THAT FIRST HAPPENED WITH THE
MUSKA, THE SHIP THAT UKRAINE
SAFRPG, AND THEN IT HAPPENED IN
CRIMEA.
NOW UKRAINE IS FIGHTING HUNDREDS
OF MILES INSIDE OF RUSSIAN
TERRITORY.
AND THERE WAS NO AIR DEFENSE
AGAINST WHATEVER STRUCK THOSE
AIRFIELDS.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IS
FASCINATING TO ME IS AIR DEFENSE
FOR THE RUSSIANS ARE EITHER
S-400 OR S-300 MISSILE SYSTEMS.
P RUSSIA IS USING THOSE AGAINST
CIVILIAN TARGETS IN UKRAINE.
THAT MEANS THEY'VE TAKEN THEM
AWAY FROM DEFENDING AIRFIELDS
WITHIN RUSSIA SO I'M SURE THERE
ARE VERY EMBARRASSED AND
EGOCENTRIC RUSSIAN GENERALS
SAYING HOW DID WE ALLOW THAT TO
HAPPEN AND BE QUESTIONED BY THE
CIVILIAN POPULATION AS WELL.
>> HUNDREDS OF MILES INSIDE OF
ITS TERRITORY.
YET ONE MORE THING WE'VE LEARNED
FROM RUSSIAN MILITARY
CAPABILITIES, MARK HERTLING,
THANK YOU SO MUCH.